as women
are we
are we trying to achieve something
that shouldn't
be achievable meaning
should we feel good every day should we
have high energy should we be high
producing should we look a certain way
should we never age should we have you
know super low body fat should we be you
know great lean muscle mass like is
there an
uh a problem with the objective um
what a fabulous question that is
so
parts of the answer parts i was nodding
to parts of the quest the beginning
parts like should we feel good every day
absolutely should we have high energy
every day absolutely like those types of
things are actually just clear and
straightforward
biofeedback from your body your adrenal
system your nervous system you know all
of these things your immunological
system yes you should be operating at
your optimal state of flow
right that is that is what nature wants
for you okay and every system in your
body is designed to
make sure that it's maintaining the
homeostasis that's required from us
intracellular level to uh
you know hormone level to you name it
blood sugar level so that you can
have that optimal state of being
if we're now shifting to questions
around
physical appearance
whether that be weight
or
i don't know wrinkles or whatever right
then it comes down to
um
you know i'm somebody who's maintained a
60 pound weight loss for two decades
right
and i did that by
not deprivation not over exercising but
by really putting the focus not on the
weight loss
but on supporting my biological rhythm
right
so i think if you are struggling with
some symptoms that you're not happy with
that are
biofeedback from the body that there
might be inflammation or stress or
disruption right or premature aging
which is not a good thing right
then again the focus should not be
let's say
i don't have liposuction or some extreme
thing to
fix the problem we should look and say
what could i do to more deeply support
the systems that are giving me this
biofeedback that are crying out for help
so it's more just a shift what i like to
call
you know
active listening
and you know compassionate responding
right so
part of the issue is that
you know gloria steinem said this a long
time ago i said this to open up i think
my ted talk a long time ago which is
that from a young age little boys are
taught to view their bodies as a tool to
master their lives and environment
whereas little girls are taught to view
their bodies as a challenge or a problem
that they always have to work on
that is a profoundly different
way of orienting yourself
to your life
with your body you know as your partner
right
so
if you were to adopt the mindset that
your body is a tool with which you can
master your life and you do that as a
woman
then if you heard a symptom coming from
your body like excess weight you would
not say gee let me go find
x
xyz
fix it would be okay
what how do i how do i fix this how do i
take action and have leadership around
this issue
such that i that i can see that my body
is getting the inputs that it needs
you know that's it's really that very
simple you change your inputs the body
changes its outputs it's a that's what
biofeedback is all about
so if you want to have weight loss as
for example as a goal
it isn't actually for women just about
reducing restricting calories and
working out more that actually will get
you to gain weight turns out
so
i read that and i was like what
all these years i've been doing that and
it's just getting me nowhere fast yes in
fact that is exactly where it's
happening so
you know really looking at how do i work
smarter not harder and then i like that
word of like you know shifting the
objectives i don't think it should be on
fixing the problems that you're having
it should be about oh
my body's having a problem which means
i'm screwing up the inputs
what do i do to fix the input so that my
body stops having a problem that i'm
likely creating or at least contributing
in large part to right
then that can be said about weight that
can be said about premature aging that
can be said about um
you know i don't know what
any basically most things right unless
you have some sort of disorder or
genetic factors you know most of these
things that are metabolic um it really
comes down to our inputs
i found it fascinating
i'm curious of what some things that we
can do are um but the first thing that
that to like talk about and move aside
is i i can't believe that
like with birth control you don't have a
regular cycle
and i mean that's just crazy to me and
um i don't feel like i was ever told
that i know
i know so
you're right you weren't
that's true i can't
can't argue with that either yeah and
how many times that wants to be given to
you to solve things right right oh you
have this i'll give you that oh i have
this you know um listen symptoms or
whatever and so what are the
repercussions that's really what i'm
curious about i mean it's a bummer that
we don't know and i don't know uh maybe
they don't know uh maybe uh but they're
they're very forthcoming now at least to
say that you know these
taking synthetic birth control of any
kind does not fix
you know your pcos or your fibroids it
doesn't it's not a cure
um
but it's the best tool that they
currently have
based on the very little bit of research
and funding that that research has
received around women's you know chronic
gynecological issues i mean
let's not forget that the most commonly
performed surgical procedure uh is a
hysterectomy because that is seen as the
penultimate solution
after a lifetime of chronic gyn issues
is just to remove the quote unquote
offending organ right which you know if
you think just like put that into
context in the male body
there is no analog surgery
right
so
you know but
some 70 year old dude walked into his
gp's office 30 years ago and when the
doc asked him how he was he said oh hey
yeah everything's good i've got a new
younger girlfriend she's 50 you know
what can i do about my erection doc and
then all of a sudden in 1992 because of
the flood of funding that went into the
research to try to solve this problem
for this 70 year old guy that's not
having a life-threatening health problem
or a even
all-encompassing health problem let's
say like fibroids is with pain or
endometriosis is with pain right
1992
nitric oxide was named the molecule of
the year and then we had not one not two
but four medications developed for
erectile dysfunction back in the 90s
right i mean you remember al gore got on
the news talking about his erection
right
but we can't put um
advertising about menstruation on
facebook or the subway in new york or i
mean it's like but but al gore can talk
about his ed in the 90s
right so
so because there isn't equitable
research and funding taking place the
best treatment that you will hear from a
conventional practitioner is you know
this is what we've got this medication
is the best we've got and that's true
it's the best they've got doesn't mean
it's the best
but it's the best they've got and then
what you should know about it is that it
does not fix
or solve or cure
whatever is wrong with your hormones
what it does do is it shuts them off
you do not ovulate you do not menstruate
so it does that
any bleeding you're having is not a
period it's breakthrough bleeding and
you are uh told your expectations are
set that that might eventually go away
because they don't want you to panic
because you you actually do still think
you're having a period when you're not
right so you're not having a period
period goes away
first thing you should know second thing
you should know is that that the
synthetic hormones strip your body of a
lot of the key micronutrients that your
endocrine system needs to function
optimally at its most basic level like
vitamin d3
and omega-3s and magnesium and
b6 and i mean there's a whole thing
so it's depleting you so it's actually
putting you in a deficit that you may
not have had when you started taking the
medication and then third
how good could we feel if we just fix
this
and then third
um
dr sarah hill wrote a book called your
brain on birth control you're not
actually the same self it turns out it
creates a fundamental personality shift
you're not who you are naturally well of
course because it's shutting off this
whole cyclical rhythm which affects your
brain patterns the female brain 1996 dr
catherine wooley discovered at
northwestern university that the female
brain changes up to 25 over the course
of the month but then that's taken from
you when you take this medication
a lot of women find that when they're on
that medication they feel confused about
what they want what they're passionate
about from a career point of view then
they go off i cannot tell you how many
times this has happened to just with
people i've worked with they go off the
medication all of a sudden they're super
clear they change careers and they
become you know like they have their the
career of their dreams right same thing
can happen with relationships we know
that when you're taking synthetic birth
control you're actually attracted to
someone that you wouldn't normally be
attracted to
and then when you go off the medication
there is a risk that you literally won't
be able to stand the smell of this
person
anymore
not to mention you're not an optimal
immunological match from a reproductive
capacity so um when you're not on
synthetic birth control you're attracted
to someone who is
genetically the most different from you
and you
this is all happens very subconsciously
through you know whether or not we
believe in pheromones those haven't been
actually proven in humans but you know
this whole idea that we are attracted
somehow based on something in the smell
of the person that we're attracted to
that lets us know that they're as
genetically variant from us as possible
which then
increases the chance that you will have
a very healthy office child right
when you're on the synthetic birth
control you are attracted to someone who
has a very similar smell you're more
genetically similar and so it can have
effects on your future children's health
right
um you know women are definitely not
aware of all of these consequences when
they're taking this medication and then
what the other really amazing thing is
that
it's 2021 right
we
have technology now that we can use if
if the only reason why you're taking it
is to prevent pregnancy which is a
wonderful reason to have access to birth
control we should have as much access as
we want
if that's what you want
i have some great updates for you okay
which are
first and foremost you need to know that
you're only fertile for 48 hours when
that egg drops right during ovulation
that is the longest viability time for
the egg it doesn't live the whole month
in the uterus right it's just 48 hours
sperm if you're in a heterosexual
relationship which many of you are not
if but if you are
um
the sperm can only live in your body for
five days which gives you a maximum
fertile window of seven days
so just if you think again i am nothing
if not logical if you just think about
the math right why would you
throw a you know heavy-handed approach
of medicating daily for the reality of
being fertile really a maximum of seven
days
and so it's just kind of um it's
becoming a more outdated approach in my
opinion from a reproductive planning
point of view especially now that we
have some really cool advances in the
femtech community that allow you to have
again sovereignty and agency over your
fertile window right so you can use an
app like the daisy tracker that's going
to track with you know wireless
bluetooth your basal body temperature
it's going to chart it for you you don't
have to get out pencil and paper and do
this anymore or you can use like the
mira app which is going to check your
luteinizing hormones you urinate on a
bluetooth strip and then it measures
that hormone if you don't have an lh
surge you're not you know what i mean
it's like there there are precise ways
that you can measure ovulation now to
the minute
and then
once you have that data you have
agency now you can make some choices
you can use barrier methods
you can
you could abstain if you wanted to if
you felt really concerned
or there's even some new fda approved
products on the market like there's a
product called fexi it's a vaginal
vaginally inserted gel that changes the
ph of your vagina making it completely
inhospitable to sperm they cannot do
what they do
they can't even get to the cervix and it
just comes out on its own you don't have
to do anything you just put it in there
set it and forget it